dragonfly wings fashioned from an old
umbrella
fishbones made of spoons and a wasp
created out of old typewriter bits these
16 eye catching sculptures at London's
sled more gallery were created hundreds
of miles away in the town of Rennes in
northwestern France
it's home to French artist ed Watson a
general Vacco so although it all started
while I was on holiday at the time I had
a friend who was a painter and I decided
that I wanted to make things out of bits
and pieces I'd collected my first
sculpture was a mosquito made of old
bicycle parts that was back in 1989 and
I've just kept going ever since a piece
I did not like upcycle creating the
sculptures takes months Martyn a is not
one to buy his parts at the hardware
store instead he goes after the scrap
metal no one else wants
like I'll collect anything that has an
interesting shape I put some of the
parts away but those which inspire me
are you straight away I get the old
medal at flea markets that exchange
points outside the city often junk
dealers who collect everything so DC for
Nicky like you get that guy it's been
quite a successful haul and while Marty
day has picked up old handles broken
typewriter parts and even a little
frying pan the artist decides to create
a dung beetle from the parts so this is
the beetles stomach this is the chest
and here's that a qualified graphic
designer
martini likes to work on several pieces
simultaneously most of all he likes to
create detailed sculptures of small
animals such as insects and fish
his passion for insects goes back to his
childhood I wanted a teacher who was an
entomologist
he used to delight the whole class with
his stories exist well you got club dude
and that stayed with me to this day
the IP samira steve non-local the artist
refuses point blank to solder or braze
to assemble the parts he only uses tiny
screws that he finds among the scrap
metal
I use these tiny screws to connect small
parts from an aesthetic perspective I
think it's nice to see the finished
sculpture as a whole before identifying
the individual parts from which it's
made they kept plate but you thought you
were gonna sleep yes yes I like it when
people say yeah look there's a spoon and
that's a headlight Indian War me I play
but the teeth head while martini is
evidently on to a winner all of the
sculptures on display at the London
Exhibition have already been sold art
lovers collectors and companies pay up
to 20,000 euros per work people just
love them they come in with their
smoking past it pulls them into the
gallery yeah you know we sell everything
almost the minute we get it because what
is special about the art of art in a is
the combination of his sculptural talent
and the parts of the things that he
makes them from they than incredibly
unusual and really really clever the
exhibition runs until the end of this
month then the sculptures will be
shipped off to their new owners in
Thailand the United States Canada and
Russia